The day Sony Pictures, Disney, and Marvel
Studios' Spider-Man deal came to an end is
one that will live on in infamy.
The news was and remains a huge deal.
Since Sony and Disney, the parent company
of Marvel Studios, were unable to renegotiate
the terms of their original 2015 deal that
saw Marvel producing Spider-Man movies with
Sony retaining ownership, Tom Holland's Spider-Man
is out of the Marvel Cinematic Universe, potentially
for good.
Fans the world over were shocked upon hearing
the news, and it's no exaggeration to say
that the response to Spider-Man leaving the
MCU has been emotional.
Pop culture junkie, comic book enthusiast,
and filmmaker Kevin Smith took to Twitter
to beg Sony to agree to Disney's terms and
keep Spider-Man in the MCU:
"NOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOO!!!!!!!!
Just stop it!
Please, @SonyPictures - give @Disney what
they want and many millions of us will keep
giving you our money!"
Smith's tweet was in reference to the reports
that Disney requested a 50 percent co-financing
share in the Spider-Man film franchise, and
asked to retain producing status on future
films, credited to Marvel Studios president
Kevin Feige.
Sony is said to have flat-out refused the
proposition, as there was evidently no way
the studio would be comfortable with increasing
Marvel's current five percent cut of the franchise's
first-day profits to a 50 percent stake.
On that note, Uproxx senior entertainment
writer Mike Ryan argued that Sony is in the
right for walking away, as it would be unreasonable
to expect the studio to bump up Disney's share
from five percent to 50 percent.
Ryan posted on Twitter,
"People seem to be mad at Sony for Spider-Man
and the MCU separating?
If you read the Deadline piece it sounds like
Disney raised its price from 5 percent to
50 percent, which is a lot!
It's not insane Sony didn't agree to that."
"I'll pay you the usual rate."
Ryan wasn't the only one who felt this way.
Marvel fan @AhmedMansoor_ tweeted that Sony
was smart not to bend to Disney's whims, given
that the studio's Spidey franchise has been
flourishing as of late.
Spider-Man: Far From Home recently became
Sony's highest-earning film of all time, its
2018 animated flick Spider-Man: Into the Spider-Verse
is an Academy Award-winner, and its Venom
franchise kicked off with an impressive $856
million worldwide pull, which recently motivated
Sony to greenlight a sequel with director
Andy Serkis.
The user wrote,
"It all sums up to money and greed.
I mean, did Disney really think that Sony
would let them share 50/50 in revenue?
10/90 max maybe?
It just became their highest-grossing movie
of the all-time.
With Venom & Into the spiderverse proceeds
it's their gold mine now."
The Twitter account for Fandom.com joked that
Feige must have had the same conversation
with Disney CEO Bob Iger that Tony Stark had
with Steve Rogers at the start of Avengers:
Endgame.
In the film, Tony told Steve that he "lost
the kid," referring to the fact that Peter
Parker got dusted in Thanos' Avengers: Infinity
War snap and there was nothing Tony could
do to save him.
Though Disney apparently did try to keep Holland's
Spider-Man in the MCU, Sony pulled him into
its web in the end.
"I don't wanna go…"
On the subject of comparing Sony to Thanos,
many feel the studio has a lot in common with
the intergalactic tyrant for not continuing
to negotiate with Disney and Marvel.
Countless others are concerned that Spider-Man's
exit from the MCU means that the hero's relationship
with Tony Stark, not to mention the ending
of Far From Home, won't be followed up on.
One user wrote on Twitter,
"How does Sony not understand that they can't
just erase EVERYTHING that has happened in
endgame?
What do they think they're Thanos now?!
Snap and you can just erase spidey from existence
and everything he's been through with Tony??!!
NOPE #SaveSpiderMan."
Another added,
"So Sony has replaced Thanos as the primary
villain of the MCU?"
Many other fans, like Twitter user @BOSSKyJo,
all but shouted their outrage.
As that user put it,
"TONY STARK DIDNT DIE TO SAVE PETER PARKER
FOR SONY TO TAKE HIM OUT OF THE MCU!
#SaveSpiderMan."
Things went from bad to worse when Sony issued
its response to the deal's apparent collapse.
A company spokesperson stated,
"We are disappointed, but respect Disney's
decision not to have [Kevin Feige] continue
as a lead producer of our next live-action
Spider-Man film.
We hope this might change in the future, but
understand that the many new responsibilities
that Disney has given him, including all their
newly added Marvel properties, do not allow
time for him to work on IP they do not own."
One fan expressed hope for some kind of agreement
to be reached in the future, directly addressing
Sony on Twitter with a post that reads,
"I respectfully request that you return to
the negotiating table and make a new deal
that will please us, the fans."
For our part, the only hope we have for Sony's
two forthcoming Spider-Man movies is that
whatever they do, they just don't make us
watch Uncle Ben die again.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
stuff are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.